um I I hear that you've been on a kind
of a journey a self-discovery journey
yeah I feel like I'm always on one I
feel like we're always ever changing and
if we're not we're boring I feel like no
matter what throughout your life you're
like healing is the most important thing
in the world no matter what and like
mistakes are meant to be made and but
the thing is about mistakes is if you
learn from them they can be the greatest
lesson you can't learn from anything
better than mistakes so I mean I've
always been on that Journey but I think
I've just been Young yeah yeah I know
that's not the excuse that isn't an
excuse but that's more just like it's I
don't believe in regrets because no I
don't have any regrets um yeah but it's
really interesting because you kind of
have to take a step back and realize
what's important in life absolutely
perspective is nice I love perspectives
me too and I love being child changing
your perspective is fantastic it is I
agree with you so dude I'm so sorry
every time I forgot I never wear bright
colors and so every time I look down I'm
like oh my God it's so shocking down
here it's so rocking rocked out and it
look yeah you look like you're in a
music video yeah well you kind of
probably looked at the Target like but
yeah yeah no I do not you won't
recognize for him I'm sorry yes I would
your eyes are mesmerizing I'm trying to
not pay attention to them
um it's it's like you it's like a bug to
a light they're so pretty I'm just
saying did your new documentary help you
with your self-discovery it's Planet sex
right yes so basically with that
documentary I didn't realize how much
this discovery of the world and
everything else around it was actually
really a journey within myself yeah so
for me it was like going through that I
was I thought I knew everything about
myself and I didn't there was so much
left to kind of discover good bad like
all of these things started coming up
and that's kind of where like in a way
doing on TV was kind of weird that was
kind of the weirdest part because I was
like wait this is a lot of personal
things I didn't really realize I would
be expressing or going through so that's
kind of what I after that's cool because
we're all very no it's amazing and I
think yes we are I think we're far more
similar like when somebody says things
they're like I can't believe I said that
a lot I'm like most of us probably think
that yeah we just don't say it out loud
I I love the show though what did you
discover on the show
um
I kind of discovered that I was still so
much a student in life I'm always going
to be that but learning that I didn't
know at all oh it's okay I discovered
that this world is so vast and magical
and if you ever feel alone there are
people in this world who will understand
you and that is one of the gifts we get
from like communication and especially
with the internet which obviously can be
bad sometimes but with that like I
always felt alone when I was going
through stuff
um but now I'm like I think we all do
which is kind of silly like I felt like
that but that it's your brain is trying
to sabotage you because it's like you're
alone you're going through this alone
but it's like you've got to get out of
that little thing yeah you just totally
went cross-eyed yeah no I think it is
getting out of our own way and letting
our ego go yeah
I know I get it I get it kick it
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]